hi I'm Ken Shawn I'm a mom to a seven
year old and a three year old and I know
that sometimes feeding kids can seem
super stressful today I'm gonna show you
three easy dinner as your kids are gonna
love and share some tips and tricks
along the way let's get to it all the
recipes we're gonna make today are super
quick because I want to help make your
life easier so first up garam masala
hamburgers so have some oil in the pan
to which I've added chopped onion and
I'm just gonna cook on medium-high heat
for about three to five minutes until
soft I make these burgers for my kids
when they are giving me a hard time with
food and just going through a
particularly picky face for no good
reason and I just know that they love
burgers and this is a great way for me
to sneak in some veggies lots of flavor
no fuss now that my onions are nice and
soft I'm gonna add garlic until it's
just fragrant for about a minute I was
inspired to add cooked onion and garlic
to my burgers because my grandma in
India I used to make lamb burgers with
onion and garlic and it has so much
flavor we're gonna tip this cooked onion
and garlic mixture into a mixing bowl so
first we're gonna add our ground beef
otherwise it wouldn't be a burger
shredded carrots shredded zucchini salt
to taste and some garam masala you want
to mix everything until just
incorporated but you don't really want
to over mix because I find that makes
the burger a little tough this looks
nice and incorporated I'm going to shape
this into a regular burger size about
four or five inches in diameter
I added garam masala to these burgers
for flavor and because my kids love it
but if you're a little bit unsure about
garam masala you can totally do
something like sweet paprika which is a
crowd-pleaser I've got my pan nice and
hot and now I'm going to cook the
burgers ooh that sizzle I think cooking
with your kids just exposes them to that
whole process of the dish coming
together they can get excited about it
they can shred the carrots you have to
have a massive tolerance for mess just
embrace the mess clean it up later have
fun with it I find five to seven minutes
on each side is the perfect time these
look ready we're gonna flip them over
bound you want to try to get a nice char
it's gonna give you so much flavor
these are sizzling they're well seared I
can smell that garnish all
I'm gonna play these guys and teach you
one more trick when we played them so
the last tip I have for this recipe is
to serve this as a burger bar sometimes
kids go through a picky phase because
they don't feel like they have enough
control over their decision making when
you set it up like a bar they just feel
like they have autonomy which is a great
way to get them trying new foods I'm
gonna build my burger I have lettuce
tomato and onion and my burger bar you
can have whatever you want cheese
pickles the choice is yours
a burger bar is the only situation where
my son will eat lettuce and I consider
that a massive mom win and now I'm
putting some ketchup a little mustard
today on the side I just have
store-bought sweet potato chips which
have a little bit more fiber and
nutrition than regular potato chips this
is a fun joyful meal which is exactly
what you want when you're cooking for
kids let's dig in that is really
flavorful mmm I don't really taste the
veggies which I'm gonna say is a win I
taste the gara masala the onion the
garlic there is so much flavor your kids
are gonna love it now that we've done a
classic kid's favorite our next dish is
a little bit more adventurous but still
kid-approved my next dish is chana
masala this is a chickpea stew with
tomato ginger garlic onion spices my
kids love it and I think it's a great
dish to introduce your kids to new
flavors widen their palates plus it's
super easy to make in by pot I have some
oil that's warmed up and to that I'm
gonna add some cumin seeds and allow
them to sizzle
for about a minute now that the cumin
seeds have kind of toasted up we're
gonna add some chopped onion we're gonna
cook this onion for like 3 minutes until
it's just softened so I grew up in India
where chana masala is an absolute kid
favorite and a staple and I really
wanted to bring that to my family table
now that I'm here now the onions are
nice and softened to that we're gonna
add some ginger and garlic and we're
just gonna cook that until fragrant for
about a minute now we're ready to add
our spices so we're gonna add a bay leaf
some turmeric cumin coriander and some
brown sugar we're just gonna saute that
for about a minute until aromatic so
we're toasting up all the spices here
we're activating all those flavors all
those aroma
so that the dish can be extra flavorful
and delicious and now that the spices
are toasted we're gonna add our tomatoes
salt and pepper so we're just gonna cook
this for about two minutes until the
spices and the aromatics are well
integrated with the tomato and now we're
gonna add our chickpeas you could use
dry chickpeas that have been soaked
overnight but then this dish is gonna
take way longer I'm a mom busy
weeknights it's not gonna happen now
we're gonna add the water tamarind paste
so we're just gonna bring this to a boil
cover simmer for 20 minutes which is my
favorite part about this recipe because
I get to pour myself a glass of wine
what's not to love about a dish that
allows me to have a mommy moment with my
glass of wine now that my channel masala
is thickened I'm just gonna add 2 cups
of spinach so I know some of you are
thinking there is no way my kid is
eating us two with green bits I hear you
but your kids might surprise you
so the spinach looks like it's cooked
down and now I'm gonna show you one more
trick as to how to get more veggies into
this meal first up I have some oil too
which I'm gonna add some rice
cauliflower so it's just a great way to
add more flavor more texture more
nutrition without kind of ruffling the
feathers too much I'm just gonna saute
this rice cauliflower in oil with a
little pinch of salt until it's softened
and then I'm going to stir in the cooked
rice the white from the cauliflower the
white from the rice just gonna melt
together beautifully and look like a
really pleasing familiar food for your
kids this is ready to go and now we're
ready to plate my son likes his chana
masala with the rice my daughter likes
them super separate it's all good I'm
also gonna add a piece of butter naan to
this and garnish with cilantro which you
can totally omit if they don't like
green bits if all they end up eating is
the rice and the naan it's fine they got
some veggies they got a familiar food
and they got exposed to a new food I
love this dish it's packed with flavor
it's super quick it's super easy
let's try I like to tell my kids make a
boat with the naan and let's see what we
can tile into the boat gotta use all the
tricks mmm on point this was delicious
definitely a pallet adventure but if you
want to go back to something safer mega
kid-approved my
dish is exactly what you want next up
I'm making chicken kabobs which is a
really classic recipe in my family first
we're gonna add onion garlic and ginger
some fresh cilantro mint turmeric cumin
coriander and paprika salt to taste
about a teaspoon and then we're just
gonna blend this all up you just want it
to come together into kind of a spice
paste okay this looks good we're just
gonna fold the spice mixture into our
ground meat when I take my son to India
for the first time my mom made like a
hundred of these no joke and put them in
the freezer and just kept pulling them
out and serving them and my son kept
eating them and I was like this recipe
is a keeper these are SuperDuper
kid-approved but they're also amazing if
you're having a cocktail party and you
wanna have some finger food delicious
mix mix mix it's like a tricep workout
okay this looks well mixed so now we're
ready to shape this into our kebabs
again I'm just getting right in there
with my hands you can use gloves I just
find it so much easier with good old
hands the shape you're going for is kind
of oblong oval ish it's a little bit
bigger than a golf ball if it starts to
feel a little sticky you can just put a
drop or two of oil on your hands which
will help it not stick as much all right
we're gonna cook these guys up so we are
just gonna brush our grill pan with some
oil and then we're ready to cook them
kebabs I'm just gonna pop these into the
pan so I'm gonna cook these on all sides
for a total of about 10 to 12 minutes so
now that the edges are starting to get
brown I'm gonna flip it oh look at that
color and then as you flip it you can
just gently brush it with oil these are
looking delicious I'm gonna show you two
different ways to plate them so here we
have some quinoa and some raw veggies
some Tomatoes some carrots you can do
any veggies that your kids like and then
we're just gonna put the kebabs on with
a magical hack to things
I just find kids will eat a lot of
things that they normally wouldn't eat
if you present them with a toothpick and
if we want a second option we can do a
pita pocket so here we have some pita
bread we're just gonna slather it with
some hummus you can also have your kids
build this themselves back to that
point about control and autonomy and
then we're just gonna put in some
lettuce some juicy tomatoes cucumbers
and a couple of kabob there's no such
thing as too much kabob let's give it a
try mmm that is delicious I can taste
the mint the cilantro the spices it's a
winner so here we have these delicious
chicken kebabs you can serve them in two
different ways however you want and my
final tip for you is to encourage your
kids to eat the rainbow ask them how
many colors of the rainbow did you eat
today we have green we have red we have
orange how can you throw in more colors
and just make it fun make it exciting
make it colorful so there you have it we
have three easy recipes your kids are
gonna love the garam masala burgers the
chana masala with spinach and the
chicken kabob if you want more recipes
like these you can find my book at spice
spice baby calm thank you so much for
watching I will see you soon
you